JOSH BARRY: Hey everybody.
Welcome to this week's Google+
Platform Office Hours.
I'm Josh Barry.
WOLF DOBSON: I'm Wolf Dobson.
How are you?
JOSH BARRY: Hey guys.
This week we're a little bit
short staffed, so it's just
going to be us folks talking
JavaScript in APIs.
And no [? Curtis Spence ?]
this week.
But if you have questions,
please feel free to ask on the
Google+ post --
WOLF DOBSON: Watching
it right now.
JOSH BARRY: On the Google+
developer's plus page.
So, JavaScript.
Just using the Google+ APIs,
and actually a lot of the
other Google APIs, is a
lot easier these days.
Especially with the newer APIs
we've been releasing, we make
it easy to call it from, let's
say, something like native
JavaScript, or from one of
our client libraries.
Actually, I'm going to do some
coding, show you some code,
and walk through some
documentation.
So we're going to switch over
to this laptop with a screen
share enabled.
WOLF DOBSON: And I'll
be right back.
Hold on.
All right.
And we're back.
JOSH BARRY: So now, the first
place to look about the
Google+ APIs is obviously
our developer site
developers.google.com/+/api.
There's a nice overview of
things like API quota,
authorization, API calls, but in
regards to JavaScript, for
anybody who's tried to call a
rest API from the browser, you
run into our friend called
Same Origin Policy which
basically prevents you from
making calls in an insecure
way that may compromise
the user.
That's a good thing in some
contexts, but it makes it hard
to use APIs.
There are newer techniques that
are part of HTML5 spec,
but there's actually ways around
in the older browsers
to allow you to call
RESTful APIs.
And we call that JSON peer,
or JSON with padding.
And the Google+ APIs
support JSONP.
And all you have to do is, in
the API you're going to call,
include a Callback parameter,
and the name of a function you
need to find within that page,
so when that [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
gets called, it actually fires
the function you specified in
the Callback with
the response.
And that's true with Google+
APIs and some
of our other APIs.
So I'm going to show you an
example of doing that.
Of course, with all new
projects, were going to start
a new project with our API
explorer So let me create a
new project right now, through
our console [? router. ?]
We're going to call this
Office Hours JS Demo.
WOLF DOBSON: That'a
a great title.
JOSH BARRY: I'll be able
to find it later.
As you see, we have
a lot of projects.
WOLF DOBSON: Comes with
the territory.
JOSH BARRY: So, to use a Google+
rest API I'm going to
enable the Google+
API service.
Got to agree to the standard
terms and conditions.
And there we go.
That service is enabled
for this project.
Now, I have a sample here,
and there's us.
So, what's going on here?
I'm actually going to use a bit
of jQuery to make this a
little faster, but this would
work in standard JavaScript.
It's just an Ajax call
with that parameter,
the Callback parameter.
And jQuery just makes it
easy to type it up.
So, right here we have
the jQuery Get JSON.
JSON is shorthand for Ajax with
JSON response, which all
of our APIs respond in JSON.
And then we pass in the end
point we want to call.
I'm going to do B1
People Search.
The query that I'm actually
going to pass is Barry, which
is my last name.
WOLF DOBSON: Are you
ego surfing?
Is that what's going on?
JOSH BARRY: Well, I know there's
going to be a reply
for that one.
WOLF DOBSON: That is true.
JOSH BARRY: And then there's
a key parameter.
So key parameter's the first
required field for all API
requests, and that's
an API key.
So if we go back to the console,
the key comes from
the API console.
And within the API console you
go to the API Access section,
and then we have this
Unique key.
Don't copy this down.
I'm going to delete it later.
But use that for each one of
your projects so we know how
to do bucketing.
And the calls will fail.
So I'm actually putting
my key.
Make sure I save that.
And then that Callback
parameter.
That's the third thing.
And this is just a string.
I'm concatenating it.
And then I'm passing in
Callback function.
I defined that function
up here.
And that function is
pretty simple.
Just take the response,
and spit out for
the different fields.
So let's try this.
I have it running already.
And there you go.
This is the first 10 results.
It's the standard page size from
this people search query.
That's using JavaScript
straight up.
WOLF DOBSON: Why don't you go
ahead and make that bigger so
you can read it?
That's better.
JOSH BARRY: And there's
me at the bottom.
Let's see.
What can I show you here?
The first thing you'll notice
is that this is not an
authenticated call.
So, for any resources that are
private, we use OAuth 2 for
all of our authentication.
And that gets a little bit more
complicated and jQuery
doesn't help a whole
lot there.
And you would have to construct
the whole key change
and the secrets.
But we do have a client library
that's in alpha, which
is the next thing I
wanted to show.
WOLF DOBSON: In this case you
were able to make the
unauthenticated call, but you
included the API key.
JOSH BARRY: Yep.
WOLF DOBSON: Which then
means you aren't
going to get bounced.
Otherwise you get a
400, or is it --
JOSH BARRY: Let's just
make up a key.
And we're going to
call this --
WOLF DOBSON: Yeah, it's some
really inadequate key.
JOSH BARRY: So if you don't
include a key, or if you
include a silly key like
this one, you get an
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] exception and
everything starts failing
because you don't have access.
WOLF DOBSON: You also, if you
don't include a key at all,
you're actually going
to end up getting --
You might actually get through
once, but you'll rapidly run
out of courtesy quota.
And so that's why we want
you to create a project
and use an API key.
JOSH BARRY: So, we have client
libraries in different levels
of completeness, or
stages of release.
For example, we have our
Java one is pretty well
supported in beta.
We have Python.
I think you worked on the
Python didn't you?
WOLF DOBSON: A little bit.
JOSH BARRY: And that's
in beta.
And then we also have our
friend JavaScript.
And the JavaScript client
library, what that does is,
allows you to do these calls,
but it actually invokes our
Discovery Service So it works
with the other APIs that are
Discovery Service enabled.
For those who are not familiar
with Discovery Service, it is
a way for us to publish a JSON
schema, a JSON definition
basically, of all the APIs that
allow a clever client
library to suck them in and
create an easy use API
interface in that
native language.
So for Python it creates
Python friendly APIs.
For JavaScript it creates
JavaScript friendly APIs.
And Ruby, and so on.
If you're interested, definitely
check out the
Discovery Service and
how that works.
It'll help you understand
the API better.
But to be honest, if you just
want to get up and running,
get one of the clients.
So with the JavaScript client,
it's JavaScript, so I can run
it from the browser.
I actually don't have to
download anything.
There's just a simple Include
I add to my page.
And then I instantiate
that API.
Once I instantiate the API
I pass in the service I'm
interested in, and it starts
dynamically building the set
of API interfaces that I need.
We're going to use Google+
obviously.
So here's the Start application
that's using the
same unauthenticated API,
but with the client.
So, how does that look like?
I have a single script Include
here at the bottom.
There's a convenient onload
ready handler that you attach
as a URL parameter
to the Include.
WOLF DOBSON: That'll be the last
thing that gets called
after the page loads.
JOSH BARRY: Yeah, so DOM on
ready, as well as the API has
been instantiated.
It fires this guy.
And you'll see there's just two
simple parameters to get
this going.
I pass in an API key.
Like I did before.
WOLF DOBSON: Probably something
not your key.
JOSH BARRY: Not your key.
I'll use the same
one as before.
And then the API you
want to load.
This one is called Plus,
conveniently.
And then the version.
And then a Callback
one that's ready.
Let me just go back to
our API explorer.
If you guys haven't seen our API
explorer, it's super handy
for working with the
Google API stack.
But that means any API that's
defined within the explorer is
available to any one
of our clients.
And that includes Analytics,
or Blogger, or Freebase.
So you can use that in Python,
in JavaScript, in Ruby, with a
convenient wrapper.
So we go back, grab
that API key.
WOLF DOBSON: And that's
highlighted in blue there.
JOSH BARRY: I'm going
to paste that in.
Because this is supposed to
feel native for JavaScript
developers, it's
Callback based.
So, you'll see that we have our
onload handler that passes
in a Callback that calls a Load
function, or On Ready
function, and then the On Ready
function has its own
Load function that calls a Make
request That Make request
builds the request and fires
it off and then passes on a
Callback for the Execute
function.
Right here is the Onload
Here's the native Make
request, and then there's a
Callback function for the
Execute with a response.
We did Inline function here.
You could have just passed it
to another function to go
ahead and handle
it separately.
What are the parameters?
For the Make request?
You build the requests, you
invoke the Request function.
Again, this is
gappy.client.plus.people.
And that's dynamically
generated from
the Discovery Service.
And then the particular
parameters for this API is
query, which we saw before, and
then you just attach an
Execurte on top of
that object.
And then we're good to go.
So, going back to the browser.
There you go.
We have the same response, and
it spit out a console.log I
think my console.log
got screwed up.
One second.
So you guys see this happening
I'm actually modifying the CSS
of the Dev Tool so we can
properly read what's happening
in the console.
I think It's not being
honored right now.
WOLF DOBSON: You can just zoom
in using the browser
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Did you?
JOSH BARRY: No.
Oh.
How do you do?
WOLF DOBSON: That's
why I'm here.
JOSH BARRY: Thanks, Wolf.
I also outputted an object
for the response.
That line is found
right here --
console.log response.
And this is the actual
API response.
It's the same response
that we got in the
native JavaScript call.
It's the same response you'll
get if you do the same query
within the API explorer.
WOLF DOBSON: And also using any
of the client libraries --
Python, Ruby.
And in fact Python and Ruby are
structured very similarly
to this, where you request a
client, once the client is
loaded then you make calls on
it, and those calls executed.
Actually, in the case of the
Ruby client, they're executed
synchronously.
So execute and they come back.
JOSH BARRY: But the neat thing
about this is, most of the
client library handles the
creating functions, and the
objects, and once you go from
there you can easily output
the different response
objects.
So we had the item we spit out,
then we had this array of
objects that we were output.
I just outputted this by name,
and we could do what
we want with that.
So now, very powerful.
It simplifies integrating with
many other Google APIs, and
also makes the Google+
API integration
a little bit easier.
It's powerful, and now with
other APIs there's
authenticated research.
Even Google+ has some
OAuth scopes.
So, how do we do that?
The client library, all client
libraries handle that, and JS
client is no different.
It's a little bit more code --
I think I should remove of these
comments -- but it's not
too much different.
So, we have the same JS include
with an Onload Handler.
And this one is Handle
Client Load.
What we do here is, instead of
just having an API key, we
have a client ID as well, and
the scopes for OAuth.
Or the way we do our
OAuth is version 23
of the OAuth 2 spec.
But you define a bunch of
scopes, you pass in which we
request, and then the user can
go ahead and authorize that in
the OAuth dialog.
So let me pass in that API key,
but when you're using
OAuth with any one of our APIs,
you have to make sure
you create a client ID.
So you go back to the API access
section, create an
OAuth 2 client ID.
We're going to just call this
OAuth Office Hours.
You can just put a display
name and logo.
This is what gets showed up in
the OAuth dialogue and it's
important for later, but for
this purpose we don't really
care about it.
You set a host name for this.
I'm actual going to use Local
Host, because we're running on
Local Host, but you would set
the domain that you're
actually calling the API from.
And you create a client ID.
You saw there's two different
types of client IDs.
If you're doing a desktop
application or some of our new
implementations as well.
And you can create multiple
client IDs
for the same project.
So if you have a JavaScript
client, as well as, say an App
Engine client, they can use
separate IDs if you want to
bucket it that way.
If you choose to sign
you application.
WOLF DOBSON: You probably do
want to bucket it that way.
You can also enter more than
one JavaScript origin.
So if you want to have a test
version and a version that is
running on your server, you can
actually enter them both
in that JavaScript
Origins box.
Which can be nice.
As he's showing there, you
can just enter more
than one in a line.
That will save you the trouble
of creating, like, three dozen
client IDs for your three
developers, or your 30
developers, I guess.
JOSH BARRY: Make sure I paste
everything right, without the
copy paste error, which
we don't have an error
response for that.
WOLF DOBSON: 418.
JOSH BARRY: [? IDZ 10? ?]
WOLF DOBSON: 418 is
not a teapot.
JOSH BARRY: Are you
a teapot, Wolf?
WOLF DOBSON: Only if
I get a 418 back.
JOSH BARRY: Cool.
So, I added a client ID.
I added API key.
The scopes, Google+ only has one
scope right now, which is
the plus.me OAuth scope, which
basically identifies the
currently logged in user.
And I pass in the API key, and
I do an OAuth dialog pop up,
which is the Authorize
API endpoint.
Which you pass in the client
ID, pass in the scopes, and
another piece of metadata, which
is basically all this
now, authorize right away.
And then we, assuming that the
user has authorized the OAuth
dialog, then there's a Callback
to handle Auth results.
And it passes that to a new
function, namely we display
some stuff.
The stuff is very similar to
what we did last time.
Everything else is the exact
same as unauthenticated API.
It just so happens that we're
choosing a simple API, but you
would have to handle the
different APIs and however you
want to display the
information.
So let's see if we copy and
pasted everything, and it's
configured properly.
So you get an Authorize
button.
You get a nice Authorize
dialogue.
So that's the name of the
project you guys set.
Allow access, and boom.
It's actually pulling in
my Google+ profile
for this demo account.
Profile picture and the name
that I set it's using OAuth in
JavaScript.
And this handles relatively
easily.
So, a note about the
JavaScript client.
That is an alpha, but we're
using it, obviously.
And we have people using
it in production.
It's pretty stable even though
it's in the alpha state.
And if you have any feedback
or bugs, there's a group
associated with the JavaScript
client where you can report
all those issues.
Wolf, any closing thoughts
on JavaScript?
WOLF DOBSON: JavaScript
is awesome.
JOSH BARRY: I agree.
WOLF DOBSON: No, it's really
useful, and it's a way to get
authentication done
very easily.
Otherwise you're writing your
own handlers, and you're
dealing with refresh
tokens, and all the
rest of that stuff.
And the JavaScript client
will hide that from you.
In a good way.
It'll make it so it's a seamless
experience for your
users, and a seamless
experience for you.
JOSH BARRY: And, you know,
just as a JavaScript
developer, the API is
pretty natural.
That Callback flow, and
dynamically generating the
objects attached for all of
the method calls, and it's
pretty nice.
Cool, well I think that's
it for the live demo.
Let's go to the plus
thread, and see if
you have any questions.
WOLF DOBSON: We have that, and
then we have this one.
JOSH BARRY: Yes.
So from yesterday.
Why don't you read it to them?
WOLF DOBSON: Are you planning to
change +1 [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
in back?
JOSH BARRY: There was a very
active interesting said on the
developers + post about
these office hours,
about the +1 button.
And in general it seemed to be
a lot of end users, which a
lot of the developers are,
talking about whether they
liked the +1 buttons, they don't
like the changes, and
their opinions on how that
affects the ecosystem.
Typically, this is developer
office hours, so we answer
developer questions, but I think
it's a fair question to
still address.
It's a very simple
answer of the
evolution of the +1 button.
The overall design direction
Google+ has been going to its
red and white theme, and we just
upgraded that original
scheme to the new one.
And the numbers seem to be in
general that people like it
and it's improving things,
so that's why
we made that change.
And of course, if you have more
feedback, the Feedback
button on the consumer version,
lower left hand
corner, is the best place
to vocalize that.
Though of course, on Google+
is also a good place to
vocalize it.
WOLF DOBSON: Another question
we got is will this be
recorded and posted
on YouTube.
The answer Is yes.
JOSH BARRY: For those who
haven't been in an on-air
Hangout, or just not familiar
with it, is a
YouTube live stream.
So we're done with this, we'll
go ahead and clean up the bits
and pieces and post that, as
well as with show notes, which
includes any sample code that
I demo, the interesting
questions need further
explanation, or links that are
interesting during
office hours.
WOLF DOBSON: One of the
questions we got also is,
looking at the code.google.com
Google+ platform issues list,
and the question was,
do we read those?
The answer is, oh yes,
we read them.
We do read them.
We read all the posts that come
in on google+developers.
Our Google group.
We do read them all.
We know about them all.
We really thank you for
reporting them.
Obviously, we bring them
to the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
teams in the cases where
that's going to help.
We talk about them internally.
And we try to keep those updated
as things change.
So yes, absolutely,
we see them.
JOSH BARRY: And the
differentiation between the
issues list versus the general
Feedback button.
The general Feedback button --
WOLF DOBSON: And when he's
saying that, he's talking
about this button that's in the
lower left hand corner.
The one if you're looking at
Google+ it's right over there.
That button, when you click
Send Feedback, goes to the
product team.
That's going to be feedback
about, I want to know how I
can post this, I want to --
JOSH BARRY: Feature requests.
WOLF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
I want to be able to share this
with these other people.
I have feedback about
those Circles UI.
Things like that.
JOSH BARRY: Or even
just issues.
General issues that you
have with Google+.
Like my screen's not loading,
or the CSS is shifting
everything to the left.
WOLF DOBSON: Those, again, just
as with the issues list,
we read them all.
JOSH BARRY: And there's huge
amounts of people who go
through all of it, sift
it, collate, send it
to the right group.
So hang out issues go to hang
outs, and stream issues go to
streams, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
go to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But we manage the developers
issue list. So those are
features that developers who
use our APIs and our other
plug-ins and such,
find issues with.
So we actually manage that list.
So we read every single
one of those, personally.
WOLF DOBSON: Oh yes.
And you're absolutely welcome
to post issues there.
Though we currently are focusing
on issues with the
Google+, platform, the rest
APIs, and the Hangouts API.
JOSH BARRY: And plug-ins.
WOLF DOBSON: Oh yes.
Absolutely.
JOSH BARRY: Plus One buttons.
WOLF DOBSON: Plus One buttons.
JOSH BARRY: The badges.
WOLF DOBSON: Personal badges.
All that good stuff.
JOSH BARRY: Also typos.
If you find any typos in
our documentation.
We're happy to fix those.
WOLF DOBSON: Oh yeah.
We definitely want
that to be good.
And that looks like pretty much
it, although there's some
disagreement over whether we're
in Standard Time or
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Time.
We're definitely in Pacific
Time, and I think it's
currently daylight savings.
So that's what you
need to know.
JOSH BARRY: timeofday.com
WOLF DOBSON: We're in Mountain
View, California right now.
Right out there,
Mountain View.
Although, no actual mountains
to be seen in Mountain View.
We're facing the wrong
direction.
JOSH BARRY: Well, that
was all the content I
had for this week.
It was a short one.
But I hope that gave you guys
a sense of what you can do
with JavaScript, with
regards to our APIs.
Of course, there's also our
favorite topic, which is the
Google+ Hangout app, which
is in developer preview.
And that's completely in
JavaScript as well.
And you may be able to use some
of the techniques you saw
today inside of a Hangout app.
I believe you have a blog that
goes with techniques, and
tips, and tricks that
you discovered.
WOLF DOBSON: It has two tips,
but they're good ones.
You go to
hangoutbox.blogspot.com.
I've been posting a couple
of things that we use.
We have an example of that
is just using JS
API inside a Hangout.
It works.
It works differently, depending
on whether you're a
gadget, versus whether
or not you're
using the iFrame solution.
Which we also posted there,
which is a way around
cross-site scripting problems,
same origin policy,
that sort of thing.
I encourage to take a look at
it, and give me feedback.
JOSH BARRY: Yeah and thanks
everybody watching the stream.
It was live, and everybody's
watching it years later.
And of course anybody who's
asking questions on --
WOLF DOBSON: People
in the future.
JOSH BARRY: Ooo, what do I
look like in the future?
For asking questions
on the thread.
I just want to make one last
note that the Office Hours is
a great place to ask questions,
including the
threat that we start around each
one, but we're here to
help in many different ways
at all different times.
Of course, you can ask us
directly on Goggle+.
Our profiles are pretty
prominent and easy to find.
WOLF DOBSON: We absolutely
recommend that you use the
Google Plus Developers.
It's google-plus-developers.
And plus is spelled
out P-L-U-S.
JOSH BARRY: And we actually
have a link from our
developers site.
WOLF DOBSON: If you click
on Discussions.
That gets read by everybody
on the team, and also our
wonderful community that
will also help you out.
JOSH BARRY: And there's actually
quite a few folks in
there now who are sort of de
facto community managers.
Pretty awesome to see.
They've played around with our
APIs, our technology, and
they've gone through some of
the struggles that you may
have, and they tend to answer
sometimes before we do.
Which is good for us.
WOLF DOBSON: Which is great.
And it's wonderful to have
such a strong community.
JOSH BARRY: And of course, the
issues list. For any things
you feel like they to be
communicated to that list.
WOLF DOBSON: And
our last note.
Especially people who having
questions or issues with the
plug-ins, with the plus badges
and the profile badges, I
absolutely encourage you guys to
post a link to your site so
that we or somebody in the
community can take a look.
A lot of times it's a matter
of, like, oh yeah, you have
this kind of iFrame
or whatever.
Or we can just look
at your console.
We can look at your code.
We can get it turned around
to a lot faster.
JOSH BARRY: Also JS
[? Fiddle. ?]
And you could have this
for JavaScript.
WOLF DOBSON: Yes.
JOSH BARRY: Cool.
I think on that note, we're
done for this week.
Check back next week for
the next Office Hours.
WOLF DOBSON: Bye.
JOSH BARRY: See ya.